I just love this man's work I love his
knowledge I just love everything about
him and he's he's on Twitter and
Instagram a twin Horst ESPN he is ESPN
NBA insider Brian when Horst how are you
Brian you're picking up on me I thought
you were talking about somebody else no
come on man
it's been a while since we've talked
talked I just again I tell you this
every time I love our chats I just love
the way your brain works and your
information and I love chit-chatting our
poll question of the day
Chris Brockman why don't we just start
this one off with a win horse to kick
this one I'll tip it all off go for it
yeah real quick they faced off last
night Brian who would you rather build
your team around Luca or Zion that's a
great question I have to qualify it by
saying that Lukas two years older so
when you you can't compare them today
you have to think about where Zion would
be in two years responsibly even though
I love with Zion does and I can't I love
watching him play responsibly in the way
the game is designed today I'm trying to
you know this is like a visceral quest
and I'm trying to give an analytical
answer you know at the perimeter player
and the healthier player although to
find the funny thing is Lucas got more
injury problems than I on recently so
you would go after Lucas sorry when it's
all said and done we'll take Luca yeah
he is amazing but grudgingly I mean has
he even worked out better more as even
surprised Mavericks do you think you
know if you watched last night's game
his hand was bothering him he's got a
bad some his ankle still isn't right
they're giving him back to backs off
because his ankle isn't right
and he made four plays and over time in
the course of about I don't know maybe
about 90 seconds of game time maybe two
minutes of game time that were just a
one a world class place but I'm not
talking about you know step back threes
pocket passes tipping out an offensive
rebound I mean he just does so many so
many things and you know you look at his
statistics he's on the growth curve you
know guards we usually don't see them
really hit their stride until year three
or four because learning to play guard
takes so much in the NBA and you usually
see a huge upswing in stats so his
statistics even
from last year when he was one of the
best rookies we've seen for Rookie of
the Year his stats are way up this year
and I suspect he's gonna keep going up
on that curve and is ion in it you know
obviously it's so difficult to come from
10 under 500 and essentially 5 games
back and catch an eighth and final
playoff spot for a team but Zion has
definitely closed the gap if you will in
a Rookie of the Year voting with Marant
one would say he has no shot of catching
him though right
for that award yeah probably not I mean
I would say to you that my vote is still
open you know two years ago I voted
joelle indeed he played 31 games he did
not win Malcolm Brogdon won but I felt
confident in that I thought I felt that
indeed was the best rookie I know it's
not the best rookie it's working in a
year I understand that because John has
been so strong and not only that they're
playing much better now and he's playing
great I want to say that I could still
see myself voting for Zion but it's
going to be hard especially if not
because of anything other than John has
been great and I think there's a good
chance quizzes are going to make the
playoffs and considering they were a
team that we thought might be tanking
that star of the season him leaving that
is just a remarkable accomplishment
Bryan win worst here in the Rich Eisen
show from ESPN so Steph Curry comes back
now and a very simple question is why I
mean why in the world would a team that
is in the running for if you will the
most ping-pong balls to set themselves
up for the future bringing us somebody
like curry back what why is this
happening three reasons number one now
the teams have finished one two or three
but the bottom all have the same odds so
it's not like it was years ago where a
win could cost you ten percentage points
on giving the top pick secondly and
Steve Kerr has brought this up you know
the the people it's chased on a plate
pay a lot of money and they want to see
Steph Curry play and part of this is
business you know you know there's you
know you're there to entertain your fans
and Steph Curry wants to play and the
third one is something that Greg Pappas
I think has taught all of his players
who played for him and Steve Kerr fits
in that for sure
Grandpop which believes that there is no
such thing as a wasted game if you watch
pop over the years he does some of his
most important work in blowout
situations either way he coaches to the
very end and not in an annoying way but
he calls timeout down 7 with 10 seconds
to go that's right but you know
sometimes like you'll say well where did
this line up that the Spurs are playing
in this playoff game where did where did
just lineup come from oh it came from
those three blowout games where they
lost back in in January he decided to do
this and and so pops his beliefs there's
nothing wasted and Steve Kerr I think
believes the same thing there's nothing
wasted that even in these few games that
he would have potentially with Andrew
Wiggins and some of these young guys who
they're trying to evaluate we can just
scan past it in the scores and say oh
they won by 15 they lost by 17 last by
25 he doesn't believe that I think all
of those are factors as they made this
choice so the fact should we read into
this I'm just connecting dots here the
anti tanking scenario that the NBA put
into place last year that cost if you
will the Knicks is I honor
well how does ion land in New Orleans in
a way or should have given better chance
for the Knicks the anti tanking rule
that the the the the worst three are all
had the same percentage has led to
Curry's return in a way I think was
playing a playing a role and certainly
playing a role in that he's gonna
probably play a representative number of
games but I advocate for another NBA
rule change and I think that the
Warriors would be amazing in this case
as I advocate for there to be a play in
tournament where the seven top seven
teams in each T in each conference make
it as as normal everything move on then
there's a assume a single-elimination
eight team in each conference eight u17s
make it a teams would play in a
three-game single elimination playing
and like like a conference tournament
where you know some team it's at the
bottom of the American East Conference
could get hot next week and win their
way in
and can you imagine if and you know I
think you know it all be the central
site I say put it in Vegas put it in
washi in DC put it in Seattle put it in
Louisville wherever you want to put it
and can you imagine the excitement level
either existed if the Warriors could
still play their way in
you know klay Thompson you know might
not have shut it down for the season in
that case I think it brings a whole new
element the NBA has discussed something
like this in tabled it because they
don't have the support I firmly think
that it's a it's a really good idea and
I think the Warriors this year are a
great example of both of both cases all
right let me let me spend a little bit
more time on this Brian when worst here
in the Rich Eisen show so did you say
single elimination or would be best of
three or was no no no no single single
elimination okay you you you you played
over five days each conference you'd
you'd play as a back-to-back in the
quarterfinals and semifinals can take a
day off and play the finals of you
stagger the two conferences so it goes
over five days it's a completely new
television product to sell and you
reduce the amount of games in the
regular season the reason they can't
reduce the amount of games in the
regular season rich because because they
don't want to lose the money sure look
imagine if you had a brand new
television product to sell I think why
do you college why do in in football why
do colleges have conference tournament
their conference the championship games
money that's right I mean what is more
representative of making the NC double-a
tournament playing 18 games over three
months to win your conference or playing
a conference tournament over four days
in a central city it's a season-long but
why do they have the conference
tournament money money right right so so
why wouldn't you and people love the
single-elimination aspect that exists a
couple years ago we had the last game of
the regular season
we had Minnesota play against Denver in
a play in Game four the last state it
turned out they happen to plan on the
lefthand season I was one of the most
exciting regular-season games
a recent memory right the game was over
time it was amazing remember why
couldn't you create that and not only
that but you you reengage the fan bases
like if you're if you're a fan right now
of the Knicks you know what do you what
do you care about what they're doing but
if they had an opportunity to play their
way in
imagine how you might do it differently
and of course they say get be the first
time they get beat in the first round
but it's also a way to go to cities that
you'd like to develop for the future you
know the MBA is really interested in
developing Mexico City for example well
you could go to Mexico City for
something like this you could go to see
how you could go to to Las Vegas or you
can play it and establish cities you
know to me this is something that the
NBA they've looked at this on and off
over the years they've gotten serious
about change we just saw how positive
change the all-star game was right um
they need to be proactive about this and
I just think that the Warriors is
something that way every year and by the
way your your reward for doing this is
you get to go be the eighth seed and you
on the other team the number one seed
has now had five or six days of rest
while you're playing so the number one
that you know you even want to be the
number one seed because you get the
entire team coming out I just think it
is something that you take the best of
college basketball and you you get a
revenue-generating opportunity that
creates something that the NBA can use
so then right now just to posit this
you're you're the Utah Jazz at 39 and 22
and obviously the Rockets would have to
play another game to make it an even
number of games between the two the
reason why I mentioned that is there a
half game behind the Rockets let's just
say that there that that's the seeding
the Rockets are the four seed so they
and everybody up would get in the
Western Conference playoffs right then
and there but Utah would have to go
against Golden State
so okay the top 70 feet yes for the
tournament then for the eight feet for
the eighth and final playoff spot so the
Grizzlies would have to take on the
Warriors right now and the Blazers Ken
Spurs pelicans Suns Timberwolves we'd
have a chance to see Zion in the eighth
seed okay I like it so now right
and you get five days of single nation
basketball with the with with the
collegiate feel in markets it'd be kind
of like a it be the conference
tournament essentially so we'd started
we'd started right and and the week
would probably be right after March
Madness ends so you continue with
another tournament it's just the NBA in
early April and
teams to advance get that week off to
rest and you would you would knock out
the games would normally be played in
there so you could reduce the NBA
schedule from 82 to 74 something like
that and you could maybe eliminate
almost all back to backs during the
season so more time off during the
season and yeah you have to win three
games in four days to get in but they
have to do that in college now some of
them to college is you have to win three
games for three days to get it and then
with all that basketball from March
Madness and if you got a if your team
gets a week off you could be a fan that
load managers your television viewing
right you just take that yeah can you
imagine on your couch and for a product
like this I mean you know the NBA is
locked up for a long time on TV right
can you imagine if they put you know in
him by the way they would all play on
top of each other just like the
n-c-double-a there would be you know
three games in each conference on those
days and so you would just imagine in
Vegas oh no you would go to Vegas and
the older what theoretically watch three
NBA games just like you could do in
college now you can watch for in the
early rounds of college we do that this
year is Brian we're in we're in Rich
Eisen Cho Seon I trust me I've been
trying to sell it to New York it's it's
it's been sluggish not anymore you got
us you got us
support we endorsed we endorse your
candidacy sir we endorse unfortunately
we're out of the running but you know
you know I mean in the NBA Young gets
hot for three days oh please
words like three three straight 45
poison ups could play their way in plus
you know the games at the end of the
season even in March one you know you
know you know you're out of it you know
if you're the Washington Wizards well it
would give you an incentive to keep
playing because you would say well we
don't want to have the number thirteen
say we'd like to see if we can get down
to the ten there's a better chance
spike me Spike Lee may even come back to
watch the Knicks who knows
spike could could come to this neutral
site to watch them play all right let's
get into this last thing for you Brian
when we're starting on the Rich Eisen
show the selva team movement its
beginning and I wholeheartedly and I've
been endorsing that for years with the
Knicks fans and Dolan I can't stand the
way that this man runs the business I
think he's the worst owner in
professional sports now that obviously
Donald sterling
is out so now my question for you is
Knicks fans that hope that Adams silver
or the NBA front office will
quote-unquote do something as Charles
Oakley is advocating is there any
possibility of something like that
happened how is this being viewed in New
York City with NBA management no way you
know I mean it was funny when when when
a report surfaced that Leon Rose was
going to be the team president which by
the way were true he put out a statement
basically denying it but the beginning
of the statement he just said by the way
I'm not selling the team and I thought
was funny I just don't know if that's
gonna now be his every time they were in
the next release a statement just gonna
be in there a Knicks announce bobblehead
giveaway schedule by the way Jim doles
not selling the team Knicks announce you
know watch party for the draft by the
way Jim doles not selling the team like
it's like a total no-brainer not only
that if he would have put the team for
sale you know you've got two teams plus
the guards and I know they're breaking
them up did different companies all that
stuff but you'd need to just to buy the
Knicks trade off I think you'd need at
least four billion dollars and that's
gonna limit the amount of people could
one I mean you know Jeff Bezos if he
wanted to buy a team you know come in
and buy the Knicks but it's not a whole
lot of people out there who could buy it
for that price and and it doesn't even
matter because he's not selling anyway
thank you Brian
really appreciate the two cents here
large sample size theater available on
Spotify that's your podcast correct sir
the hoop collective but that was our
that was our episode last week okay very
good but uh thank you sir but whatever
the names are just corny oh my god so
you can hear more of my bad ideas will
be rejected by the NBA listen man I love
the idea it's not a bad idea at all like
we're all we all can't get enough of
brackets and bracketology and then once
a good by the time the NFL you know
there's like three ownership committees
that sit around and plot how they can
figure out to get more game here's a
golden plate opportunity to get more
meaningful games it's one of the things
that leagues
die for it here it is right here they're
right on table alright Brian thanks for
the call I really appreciate about chat
again
you got its Brian when worst a twin
worst ESPN